We Begin tonight with the Fox News Alert
according to reports former president
Donald Trump could be indicted in New
York as early as tomorrow or sometime
next week maybe not at all but odds are
looking the other way the chatter
tonight is loud that this indictment can
come as early as tomorrow and an
arraignment would be in New York next
week now still the far left Manhattan
D.A you know took on this zombie case as
they call it against trump it is looking
increasingly weak and blatantly
political to Legal experts on both sides
of the aisle now coming up we're going
to hear from Trump attorney Joe takapina
he's taking on this case also two people
that testified in front of the New York
grand jury one has not spoken before
kellyanne Conway and she will tell her
story here for the first time and Robert
Costello Costello is a prominent U.S
attorney former U.S attorney and once
worked as a legal advisor to the state's
star witness Michael Cohn he now says
the cone is a is totally unreliable and
on a revenge tour against Donald Trump
it is important to note Michael Cohn is
a convicted felon a tax cheat and
admitted liar and a fraud but new
yorker's very weak case does hinge
seemingly on this testimony now
absolutely about an alleged
non-disclosure agreement from what seven
years ago in a 2018 statement Michael
Cohn said this about the agreement quote
in a private transaction in 2016 I used
my own personal funds to facilitate a
payment of a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars to miss Stephanie Clifford AKA
Stormy Daniels neither the Trump
organization or the Trump campaign was a
party to this transaction the to the
payment of Miss Clifford it was lawful
it was not a campaign contribution or a
campaign expenditure by anyone now Alvin
Bragg is trying to prove the exact
opposite with a completely different
story from Cohn and not only is the D.A
relying on an unreliable eye of old
dishonest star witness with conflicting
statements but he is also attempting to
do something without any legal precedent
brag is trying to take a misdemeanor two
years outside the statute of limitations
and upgrade this to a low-level felony
likely also out of the statute of
limitations using a novel legal Theory
surrounding a New York campaign Finance
law and it was referred to as a zombie
case because it keeps coming back from
the dead even though they look at it and
they say no there's nothing here the
prior D.A in New York declined to pursue
these charges the doj also declined to
pursue them as did the FEC now here we
are years later and this is all pretty
insane but predictable because if the
dog bites the Beast thinks you're
feeling sad let's blame Trump let's
impeach Trump let's have a hoax against
Trump let's now indict Trump but we all
know what's happening here this is
political Vengeance Justice is not blind
there is no longer in this country and I
say this with a lot of sadness Equal
justice under the law or equal
application of our laws sadly we do have
a two-tiered system of justice it is
alive It is Well we have chronicled it
often on this show and especially in the
state of New York in fact on the
campaign Trail Alvin Bragg he vowed he
made a pledge a promise a solemn vow
that he would convict Donald Trump one
way or another take a look
a lot of people are wondering uh whoever
has this job
are they going to convict Donald Trump
look that that that is uh the number one
issue I'm the candidate in the race who
has the experience with with Donald
Trump I was the chief Deputy in the
Attorney General's office we sued the
Trump Administration over a hundred
times I'd be hard to argue with the fact
that that's that'd be the most important
uh most high profile case and I've seen
them up front and seen the lawlessness
that he can do and you believe it should
happen
I I
believe we have to hold them accountable
okay that's the number one issue you're
running for office to be Manhattan
District D.A getting Donald Trump that's
your top issue over a non-disclosure
agreement from seven years ago not rape
not murder not theft nope now is this a
system of justice that we really want in
this country now sadly the legal system
we now know has been weaponized we have
now criminalized political differences
somebody should tell Alvin Bragg that
this is called persecution not
prosecution Alvin Bragg has given
violent felons the best deals imaginable
in fact Senator Rand Paul is now calling
for brag to be locked up uh quote a
trump indictment would be a disgusting
abuse of power and the D.A should be put
in jail now think about this Bragg is
dedicating valuable time limited time
resources millions of taxpayer dollars
to prosecute a cooked up misdemeanor
case involving Donald Trump all while
giving actual violent criminals of free
pass in his very first memo he
instructed his staff to seek misdemeanor
charges for perpetrators accused of
armed robbery so long as no one was
seriously injured but it's not just
armed robbery under Bragg 52 percent of
all felony cases get reduced to
misdemeanors and of the felony cases
that he actually tries he's lost 49
percent of them that is an atrocious
record by any account in September a man
named Justin Washington he got a
sweetheart deal from Bragg after
allegedly raping a teenage relative
Washington was set to serve just 30 days
in jail before terrorizing five more
victims here's another sweetheart deal
handed out to the perpetrator of a
vicious anti-semitic beating in Midtown
Manhattan Bragg also reduced the charges
for a man who attempted to rob the same
Pharmacy twice in one day at knifepoint
the man had a lengthy rap sheet with
more than 20 arrests Ray tape robbery
assault other crimes Alvin Bragg didn't
care in another case the perpetrator had
46 prior arrests and was out on parole
but Bragg once again he reduced the
charges so it's no surprise that major
crime is on the rise in New York City
under Bragg and according to foxnews.com
and the Daily Mail Bragg's campaign was
funded by a massive donation from a
soros-backed political action committee
and like many other far-left Soros
funded prosecutors across the country
Safety and Security is a low priority
for Alvin Bragg instead he's more
interested in keeping his campaign
promise to get Donald Trump and Advance
a political agenda it is deeply
unethical and it's now obvious to
everybody including even people on fake
news CNN and msdnc I never thought I'd
see the day take a look the facts are
old they're six or seven years old and
the star witness here in the form of
Michael Cohen Donald Trump's former
attorney has credibility issues been
convicted of crimes and so you know to
your point Abby as far as the strength
of a case it's certainly not the kind of
Slam Dunk that many people would wish
that it worked you have to be careful
when you put a witness on the stand who
has a motive for revenge and Michael
Cohn has said many times he would like
to get Donald Trump in one way or
another so does it concern me yes have I
done things like that sure in this New
York case the facts of this case
um going on almost seven years now are
really stale I hear my conservative
friends saying he's they're being
overcharged it's so so aggressive it's
so terrible welcome to my world folks
prosecutors over charging being over
aggressive being ridiculous with with
minor stuff and turning it into major
stuff happens every single day in
America every courthouse in America
now as you can see lawyers and pundits
on both sides of the aisle are now
admitting Alvin breaks cases weak and it
is reckless hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else